[Music]
over the past five years breath of the
wild has been broken apart pretty
thoroughly by players with constant
discoveries of new glitches one of the
most sought after by far is weapon
duplication with the addition of the
weapon durability system that nintendo
implemented that causes weapons to break
easily players have wanted this glitch
more than ever and we've achieved it but
just how many ways are there to do this
most players think of just menu
overloading the most popular method by
far but there are tons of variations of
this and many other strange methods you
may not know so if you want more breath
of the wild videos from us let us know
by liking this one
let's start with one method that's not
quite as well known bone arm duplication
by breaking apart a stall enemy and
taking their arm just as they pick it up
the game will think that you took the
weapon but you are technically
empty-handed
so by switching your weapon and taking
the arm back the game thinks that you
have the arm equipped but you have a
different one instead which is called
inventory desync throw the weapon in
your hand on the ground and send to
things that you threw the bone arm the
duplicate weapon is then created
shock trap duplication was found early
in breath of the wild's life and made
farming for weapons with specific
modifiers much easier by swinging a
shock weapon and dropping it mid-swing
on something metallic its infinite shock
effects continually disarm enemies when
placed beneath their feet so by resting
at a campfire the enemy will repeatedly
drop the weapon over and over each new
day making a mountain pile of dropped
weapons
menu overloading is one of the most used
glitches with its versatility of
duplicating and transferring durability
of different weapons a glitch that is
highly sought after there are a ton of
different ways to trigger this from
enemy encampments using multi-shot shock
arrows dropping multi-shot shock arrows
yourself a mixture of the two dropping
two multi-shot shock bows with your back
to the wall and even escaping the final
boss fight then entering and exiting
certain areas hundreds of times triggers
menu overload once overloaded switching
and dropping weapons by throwing
shocking yourself putting it on a weapon
rack and more lets you duplicate the
selected weapon
octo balloon duplication is one of the
newer methods of multiplying your
weapons by having your back to a wall
using magnesis and dropping an octo
balloon this causes the balloon to drop
directly beneath your feet dropping a
weapon on this shortly after can give
you a chance to pick up the weapon off
the balloon twice duplicating the weapon
dynamic object duplication is a much
more simple technique but slightly more
tedious timewise normally when opening a
treasure chest it's a one and done deal
and after taking the goods it never
appears again but by bringing any
dynamic object which includes some
treasure chests with equipment in them
two map grid spaces over in any
direction opening it then doesn't
actually count as taking it out so it's
possible to continuously grab the same
item over and over albeit with a little
bit of walking
the next three methods are based off the
same model teleport mechanic which is a
glitch that confuses the game on where
link's position actually is and giving
you a split second to desync equipment
on you one way to trigger this is the
horse sliding method horse sliding is a
glitch that lets you launch off your
horse in different ways this method can
be triggered by shield jumping on the
rear end of a horse while it's slanted
on a hill riding forward a small
distance then jumping off launching you
backwards towards your original position
but doing this as you over spur your
horse jumping off and throwing a weapon
at the same time then switching quickly
desyncs your held weapon now your throne
weapon pops out but doesn't leave your
inventory because you technically had a
different weapon equipped so it becomes
duplicated
the standard model teleport method
requires using a horse at a slant
unequipping your shield at a specific
moment while link is tilting sideways
gives you a moment to de-sync and
perform a duplication glitch
always satisfying to see
finally pulse skew duplication is
arguably the most difficult duplication
technique of all it consists of getting
a specific skew and skew setup to get a
reusable skew that flips link upside
down the combination of damaging
yourself with ragdoll glitch engaged
confuses the game on where link's
position actually is and gives you a
moment to desync and duplicate the
throne weapon i've done thousands of
glitches over the past several years but
this one was just too tough for me oh
well
what do you think of these weird methods
and how many of these did you know let
us know in the comments below and for
everything else gaming keep it here on
gamespot
[Music]
you